Philippe lean rebonjour vous êtes le
président de l'association jeanmonet
alors on a évoqué déjà dans une première
émission bah la la un peu la biographie
de de de Jean Bonet depuis sa descence
jusqu'à la fin de la 2e guerre mondial
et le moment où il est nommé commissaire
général au Plan où crée le Commissariat
général au Plan pour relancer l'économie
en France notamment et puis bon on
arrive aux années 50 et il y a toujours
cette idée qu'il faut il faut s'unir il
faut une Europe unie il faut finir avec
la
guerre main de la guerre et puis il faut
finir parce qu'économiquement c'est
important
oui et jean-monis a un plan pour cela
qu'il avait d'ailleurs depuis déjà 1943
en tête c'est de commencer par le nerf
de la guerre par l'énergie et le la
matière première avec laquelle on fait
les armes c'est le charbon et l'acier
c'est la roue et la Lorine c'est
finalement dans l'histoire de de
l'Europe des des contrées où on s'est
toujours fait la guerre pour ces
matières premières et donc son plan
c'est ça c'est euh remettre sur un pied
égalité les vainqueurs et les vaincus
pour la première fois dans l'histoire de
l'humanité un pays vaincu comme
l'Allemagne et bien on ne vient pas
l'occuper et lui prendre son charbon
mais on vient se mettre en commun le
charbon et l'acier dans dans un un
marché commun dans un dans une une
communauté et et ça c'est tout à fait
unique dans le dans l'histoire et mais
pour ça il lui faut un homme politique
pour porter ce projet là oui parce que
c'est un projet d'abord il est c'est un
c'est malin de commencer par au fond par
l'économie enfin par il y a pas
tellement d'autres choix en 1950 quand
même on peut pas dire voilà on va faire
une alliance politique immédiatement
avec l'Allemagne encore on est 5 ans
après la Guer donc il faut en effet
parce que lui alors peut-être une
question comme ça entre parenthèses mais
pour pourquoi au fond n'a-t-il jamais
voulu lui se lancer directement dans la
politique B il considérait que il
considérait que c'était pas son rôle lui
était là pour amener des projets les
faire fonctionner et c'était pas du tout
son rôle d'être sur le devant de la
scène et à chaque fois qu'on lui a
proposé oui oui on lui a proposé de de
se présenter à des élections et cetera
il a toujours refusé voilà c'était il
préférait le concret l'action euh plutôt
que les que d'être emprisonné aussi puis
il était très libre il voulait il
voulait rester indépendant et libre de
penser et donc mais par contre il savait
évidemment qu'il lui fallait voilà un
relais politique quelqu'un qui avait pas
peur de jouer sa carrière parce que
c'était quand même gros et Robert
Schuman était l'homme de la situation
Lauren
euh respecté de en
France pas pas associé à un quelconque
scandale comme on aurait peut-être
aujourd'hui enfin un homme intègre et et
Schuman est est absolument s'engage à
fond dans ce ce proj il le porte
politiquement voilà il engage la France
alors qu'il n'était même pas Premier
ministre mais qui était
ministre des affaires étrangèes c'est
lui qui engage la France et qui en parle
aussi au chancelier Adenauer et qui
chansonnier adenower après quelques
instants de méfiance en disant qu'est-ce
que c'est que cette proposition que nous
font les Français comprend que c'est une
chance historique et que c'est sérieux
et que c'est honnête et il s'engage
aussi au nom de l'Allemagne donc on va
voir la naissance de la SEA hein de la
communauté du charbon et de la Cé la
première communauté et qui qui est au
fond la matrice de de oui et et les
institutions créées à l'époque par Mony
Schuman pour faire fonctionner cette CK
sont à en tout point semblablebl
finalement déjà les les les ancêtres des
institutions que nous avons aujourd'hui
dans l'Union européenne et lui devientoi
une sorte de président de la commission
voilà il devient une sorte de président
de la commission il devient président de
la Haute autorité supranationale qui
contrôle le le fonctionnement et qui qui
organise le fonctionnement de cette
communauté qui ne dépend ni d'un état ni
d'un autre et euh il y a aussi déjà à
l'époque une cour de justice qui est
créée pour régler les différents
commerciaux et cetera il y a euh un
parlement aussi qui existe c'est des
représentants des représentants des des
parlements des pays membres sont nommés
là aussi ils ont pas encore beaucoup de
pouvoir non mais ils sont là donc tout
tout ça est déjà euh et puis évidemment
le Conseil des États enfin les
représentants des États donc on a
vraimentganisationtionn aujourd'hui et
ça ça va aboutir évidemment au 57 au
traité de Rome alors le traité de Rome
c'était pas forcément euh déjà dans les
têtes en 1950 mais il y a il y a il y a
un épisode qui qu'il faut rappeler c'est
en 1954 l'échec de la Communauté
européenne de défense que jean-monis
avait appelé de ses vœux et qui avait
été pratiquement bouclé les états
l'avaient tous accepté et c'est
finalement la France qui le qui
rejettera sous les gouvernement Mendes
France qui votera non le le le la
Chambre des députés et donc le projet
n'aboutira pas et et Mony bon sur le
moment est très déçu mais il se dit il
faut qu'on continue quand même
l'intégration européenne voilà donc il
part à ce moment-là plutôt réfléchir sur
les aspects
donc de marché commun et c'est ce qui
donnera la conférence de Messine d'abord
dans laquelle les États-membres vont
préparer les sujets qui seront définis
dans les traités avec venir et les
Traités de Rome on il y en avait deux le
traité du Marché Commun de la
communauté économique et puis le traité
euratome pour le marché commun de de de
l'énergie atomique civile qui n'est pas
très connu mais qui vra qu'on parle
politique mais important euh donc c'est
c'est voilà c'est c'est quand même la la
naissance de de de de l'Europe grâce à
jeanmony et on est traité de Rome 57 de
Gaul revient au pouvoir en en 58 et disa
dans la précédente émission au fond les
débats qu'on a aujourd'hui sur l'Europe
est-ce qu'il faut que ça soit des
nations l'Europe des Nation est-ce qu'il
faut fa qu' qu' a une une plus grande
alliance entre l'Allemagne et et la
France est-ce que ça doit être le moteur
de l'Europe ou est-ce qu'au contraire il
faut une Europe plus intégrée c'est un
peu le débat qu'on eu de Gaul et Mony
oui ben c'est le débat qui qui depuis
l'origine hein c'est-à-dire qu'en effet
on a commencé par la France et
l'Allemagne par la réconciliation les
autres pays du Bénélux et l'Italie se
sont rejoint et puis d'autres pays se
sont rejoints ensuite mais c'est vrai
que l'origine c'est ça c'est ce c'est
cette réconciliation entre la franceemag
de Gaul lui considérait que c'était
plutôt le traité de l'Élysée en
1961a oui pour lui pour de Gaul c'était
la France et l'Allemagne et puis le
reste je crois qu'il disait c'est des
légumes France comme ça et pu il voulait
surtout pas des Anglais pas anglais il a
fait la politique de la chaise vide il
ait la politique de la chaise vide pour
retarder au maximum la la la l'avancée
européenne et surtout l'arrivée de de la
Grande-Bretagne mais déjà les bon la
politique de la chaise vide à l'époque
ça a retarda les choses mais ça ne les a
pas arrêté et c'est que l'idée c'est
enfin il pouvait y avoir selon
jean-monis des décisions qui étaient
prises à la majorité et et de Gaul
voulait qu'il y ait l'unanimité voulait
pouvoir mettre son V gros il est clair
que à l'époque jean-monet bon c'est
commence à réfléchir sur ce mode de de
de de de décision jean-monet avait été
très marqué quand il avait été à la
Société des Nations l'an de l'ONU par le
fait qu'un pays pouvait avec son droit
de vetto bloquer aDVITAM et ternam des
décisions prises par tous ça il n'en
voulait pas donc évidemment il vou les
États-Unis d'Europe cétait alors oui
alors il faut faire attention dans cette
il nous a il nous dit pas je veux les
que l'Europe soit organisée comme les
États-Unis mais je veux des États
européens qui soient unis voilà et et
justement pour être plus fort il faut
être uni c'est toujours cette ce message
qu'il a depuis ses depuis qu'il est
jeune à Cognac si nous sommes petits il
savait que l'Europe ne pèserait pas
lourd dans le monde dans les années qui
viendrait il avait cette intuition parce
qu'il le savait il ilit vu il avait
voyagé voyagé il savait faut jamais
oublier que c'est un homme d'affaire en
oui ououi et il savait très bien le
poids économique des des régions du
monde et il savait que pour que des pays
européens
enfin pacifié donc qui ne se consacrait
plus leur énergie à s'entretuer et à se
faire la guerre mais pour pouvoir
survivre dans ce monde global quelque
part il fallait qu'il soit uni et fort
voilà c'est ça son message il est
toujours d'actualité qui est toujours
d'actualité on est ici donc dans dans sa
maison à bazoch pour ceux que ça
passionne il y a des biographies hein
qui qui qui sont en vant il y a une
petite biographie qui coûte 5 €
voilàorter tous mais je voudrais qu'on
parle quand même de cette maison
jeanbonnis parce que c'est une
association
euh pourquoi elle a été créée et
qu'est-ce qu' qu'est-ce qu'on y fait
alors d'abord l'association est s'occupe
d'entretenir la maison mais la maison en
elle-même est une propriété de de
l'Europe du Parlement européen Parlement
européen qui a acheté quelques années
après la mort de jean-monay pour qu'elle
reste le un lieu de mémoire de la
construction européenne parce que c'est
ici que le projet a germé c'est ça et on
n'avait pas de lieux de mémoire on a des
lieux de mémoire qui rappellent des
batailles eu es ou des victoires mais on
n pas de lieu de mémoire qui rappelle la
paix en tant que à part les maisons de
ces hommes il y a aussi mais Robert
Schuman il y a aussi une maison Ader
mais nous en plus ici nous sommes un
centre d'information et d'éducation sur
l'Europe alors vous nous sommes ouverts
tous les jours de l'année nous recevons
tous les visiteurs et nous recevons
beaucoup de groupes en particulier de
jeunes de classes d'Île de France
principalement mais aussi des d'ailleurs
et de toute l'Europe voire des du reste
du monde auquel nous expliquons le le
plus simplement possible quel est le le
projet européen depuis son origine et
puis où on en est aujourd'hui et quels
sont les sujets de demain voilà et donc
c'est c'est c'est ce que nous faisons
donc c'était il y a une un côté
didactique enfin de de de voilà
péquetique on essaie d'expliquer ça de
manière simple parce que le reproche qui
est fait toujours à l'Europe on commence
par dire c'est compliqué oui évidemment
si on vous dit personne nexlique ou
voilà on dit c'est compliqué B mais
c'est pas plus compliqué qu'autre chose
simplement on on en parle jamais ne
serait-ce qu'à l'école il y a pas de
cours d'instruction civique européenne
vra donc bien nous nous essayons les
gens restent entre 1h3 2h de ici on
essaie au moins de leur expliquer les
bases pour qu'ils puissent y revenir une
fois rentrer chez eux ou qu'ils puissent
y réfléchir et qu'il puisse se dire bah
finalement j'ai un petit peu
compris comment ça marche donc voilà
vous organisez aussi des colloques non
on organise des colloques des séminaires
euh des colloques sur des sujets comme
nous sommes ici un établissement
indépendant de de de tout ministère
national nous nous autorisons à parler
sans tabou de n'importe quel européen
vous avez
paroleà absolu merci infiniment donc on
peut venir c'est un BASOL c'est facile
c'est bien fléché c'est facile si vous
avez quand même une voiture ou si vous
êtes un bon marcheur comme
Jean c'est en plus le village est
superbe il y a encore du cognac monnaie
il y a du cognac monnaie qui
n'appartient plus à la famille mais qui
appartient à autre société mais qui
continue à être commercialisé sous le
nom de Cognac monie et que vous
trouverez d'ailleurs à notre boutique si
ça vous intéresse merci infiniment
Philippe vous en
PR